So water would satisfy our physiological need. Earning a pay cheque would help
give us safety and security. Having a happy and secure relationship would
satisfy the love and belonging level of a hierarchy. Self-confidence would
fulfill the esteem level of the hierarchy and finally having a satisfying
fulfilling career would fulfill the self actualization level of the hierarchy.
So let's take a step back and look at masters hierarchy of needs. It makes
sense that we would need to have our physical needs met before ever considering
realizing our full potential, so to recap we need our physiological needs met
then we can move on to other safety and security needs. And once those two
criteria are met we can move on to our loving and belonging needs. Once we have
achieved love and belonging then we move up the hierarchy to our esteem needs.
And then finally self-actualization, which is the very top of the pyramid.